well your favorite superheroes take a
more adult role in upcoming movies I'm
Dave and welcome to a pg-13 gamespot
news update foxes are rated superhero
movie Deadpool was a huge hit and Batman
V Superman may get R rated home video
cup so you might be wondering if Disney
would follow suit with its own adult
orientated Marvel movies that's not
going to happen at least not anytime
soon according to Disney CEO Bob Iger we
don't have any plans to make r-rated
movies I guess said during a call with
shareholders today as reported by
polygon given that children and families
are typically Disney's core audiences i
goes comments aren't very surprising all
of Disney's Marvel Universe movies to
date have been rated pg-13 and I guess
comments today make it clear that that
pattern is not going to change anytime
soon after that Bulls huge success much
speculation emerged about what other
superhero properties will embrace them
much more restrictive rating just
recently x-men universe producers Simon
Kinberg said he thinks that x-men films
will continue to be rated pg-13 but
x-force could get an R rating
additionally images related to the
upcoming Wolverine 3 indicated the
action movie was anticipating being
rated R so would you be interested in
another r-rated Marvel movie or do you
think they should be watchable by all
audiences let us know in the comments
section below or you can find me on
Twitter at a regular Dave and for your
entertainment news stay tuned to
gamespot com
you
you